A now-infamous sentence in my play group is
“wow, this opening hand would be great if
it had more lands.” Whenever it’s said, either
me or my friend Mr. Hans will sit up straight,
get a devious glint in our eye, and say “yeah,
nine card hands are pretty good.” This is a
joke that we’ll never stop finding funny, but the
frequency with which people express the original
sentiment also speaks to a broader point about
lands. Despite their centrality to the game,
a lot of people don’t really see lands as a
part of their deck in any meaningful sense.
If your hand was missing something else you
find vital to your gameplan—an artifact,
a creature, a piece of ramp—you wouldn’t say
“wow, this opening hand would be great if it
had an artifact in it,” because that’s a
silly statement to make. An opening hand
without an artifact in an artifact deck is
a bad hand, not a mildly-flawed good hand.
To take this a step further, I think a lot of
people also have a mindset of lands being a
sort of necessary evil, a card type that dilutes
the gas of a deck, and one that should be played
in the lowest quantity the player can get away
with. I don’t necessarily want to invalidate
the desire to draw gas, but I do think that
what I just described is a mindset that will
naturally lead to deckbuilding mistakes. So to
start with, I want to lay out a basic framework
for the approximate number of lands you should be
running in your deck. I’ve seen lots of numbers
paraded around by various people as general
reference points, and to be frank I think
a single number does a poor job of answering
the question. Speaking of Frank, let’s start
there. Frank Karsten has done an admirable job
of answering questions of mana and mana-fixing,
and his analysis on the subject of land count is
as good a place to start as any for the topic.
The format-agnostic version of Karsten’s
land-count analysis goes something like
this—he takes a whole bunch of match data from
across a couple years of online MTG events,
and excludes any deck that didn’t have more wins
than losses. He then does a regression analysis on
the remaining decks, which sounds complicated but
is actually pretty simple in concept—a regression
analysis basically just cares about how a bunch
of predictor variables correlate with an output
variable. In this case, the question Karsten’s
analysis is asking is “how do mana curve,
quantity of cheap draw spells, and quantity
of cheap ramp spells affect how many lands
a successful deck plays?” The result of this
question is then turned into a formula that can
be used to determine the number of lands that a
given deck should play. And as a starting point,
I like this—I’d argue that average mana value
as well as quantities of cheap draw and ramp
should be major factors used to decide
land count in a deck, and I’ve left a
link to that article in the description if
you want to give Karsten’s formula a try.
However, since it was constructed from
60 card deck data, Karsten’s analysis
here misses out on some specific factors
involved in EDH. And he himself is aware
of this—another article of his lays out a
different set of criteria for mana curve,
ramp, and land count in an EDH-specific context.
Due to the absence of good data on EDH games,
this article obtained its findings through
simulated games against a passive opponent,
with the model optimizing for the highest quality
curve-out. This “quality” is defined here as a
single number, being composed of the mana value of
each card played, repeated on each turn thereafter
to simulate the value of having played a spell
that influences the game. The model factors in a
number of commander-specific assumptions, such
as the free mulligan and the commander being
effectively an extra nonland card available at all
times. And honestly, I like this model a lot—not
because it’s perfect, but because it’s simple
and specific. It gives land count, ramp count,
and mana curve recommendations based purely on the
goal of curving out. Cards aren’t Necropotence and
Rewind and Aquamoeba, they’re hypothetical
pieces of cardboard with mana value 3, 4,
and 2, respectively, and to assume
that they’re different than each
other beyond this information would introduce an
unreasonable level of complexity to the model.
So, as with the land count formula,
it’s a good starting point. It offers
some neat recommendations on optimal land
counts, mana rock counts, and mana curve,
and comes to the conclusion that, for purposes of
curving out properly, decks would be well served
to run at least 37 lands, and as many as 42 in
some cases. This is good information, but the
simplicity and specificity of the model mean that
to get the full picture, we need to venture a bit
beyond its scope. Karsten’s assumptions themselves
offer a neat place to start thinking, and I’m most
interested in his assumption about the commander.
His model assumes it to be effectively a nonland
card like any other, but one you have available
all the time. This is a decent shortcut for
purposes of putting together a model, but the
commander of a deck can have a wildly important
impact on the curve and desired landcount of
the deck beyond just occupying a mana slot.
Specifically, there are commanders that offer
some form of draw or filtering, and these will
influence the number of lands a deck is looking to
run. If you’re building a Rona deck with lots of
one and two cost legendaries, as long as you run
enough blue sources to guarantee playing Rona on
turn 2, your black sources and land count as a
whole can be a bit lower since you know you’re
gonna churn through a lot of cards on turns 3
and 4. Similarly, a Yasharn deck can go a bit
heavier on ramp and a bit lighter on lands knowing
that as long as it’s able to get up to Yasharn,
it’ll have its next couple land drops for free.
These examples make sense, as they’re cases when
the player will have guaranteed access to a high
quality tool for drawing into additional lands.
However, I also want to talk about a different
type of commander that I think will be more
controversial, that being the higher-costed
commander that draws a lot of cards. If your
commander costs 4 or more and draws cards, not
only should you not run less lands than you
otherwise would—you should run more. That’s
a draw spell you’ll have every single game,
and your only barrier between yourself and those
sweet, sweet cards is drawing into enough lands
or ramp to get there. Ditto if the deck
is very heavy on draw that costs a lot of
mana—medium-to-large draw will cut through that
slightly higher density of lands with no problem,
so running a higher land count won’t hurt you—it
will only serve to lessen the chance of screw. And
I’ll go a step further here—I suspect the
reason a lot of people end up running low
land counts isn’t because they’ve done lots of
field testing and have decided they need to be
drawing more gas—it’s because they get finished
adding cards to the deck and feel attached to
the nonland stuff they put in. Making cuts can
be a somewhat painful and difficult process,
so if EDHFan99 tells you that you can run 33
lands, a lot of people will take that advice
very eagerly, and then down the road they’ll
curse the luck gods when they get stuck on
four lands in their deck whose average mana
value is 4.5. And I say this with a heart full
of empathy—I’ve been there, but sometimes you
just gotta bite the bullet and make those cuts.
Another factor that should influence land count
is colors—both the number of colors and the symbol
density. Well, kind of. See, this is a subject
that’s a bit harder to solve with big-brained
deckbuilding tips. The annoying truth is if
you want to run a lot of colors and you don’t
wanna run a whole lot of taplands, in order to
actually get the colors you need, you either
need to spend hundreds of dollars on a mana base
full of fetches and shocks, or you need to run a
lot of lands. And I do not say this from sitting
atop my throne of paper mache’d copies of Rhystic
Study. I don’t run many fetches and shocks in my
decks due to their cost, and I honestly find the
effectiveness of them to be a little upsetting—if
you’re willing to spend money you can run a lot
of colors with basically no downside, and if you
aren’t willing to spend money you can’t do that.
But I’m not here to get upset—I’m here to give
you actionable advice. And that advice is, if you
can justify buying fetches and shocks, or if you
feel like proxying, you should run them. If you’re
like me and you can’t justify that purchase, you
should either play fewer colors or run more lands.
As an example of this principle, I built out four
manabases for a hypothetical four-color deck with
blue and green being dominant colors. The first
one was 30 lands, 300 dollars, and a 10% taplands
allowance—a decidedly solid manabase if you’re
okay with the low overall count. Symbols-wise,
it’s 22 each for green and blue, and 16 each for
red and black—pretty good numbers for coming from
just 30 lands, not even including any sort
of ramp. The second one was 30 lands again,
but 50 dollars this time, and a one-third
tapland allowance. The symbols for this
deck are 20 each for green and blue, and
13 each for red and black—definitely worse,
but not horrendously so, as long as you’re
okay with taplands. A well-built ramp suite
should be able to patch up those numbers to
something that ends up being pretty reliable.
The third one was 30 lands and 50 dollars
once again, but going back to the 10%
tapland allowance. This is where things get
painful—16 symbols each for green and blue,
and 10 each for red and black. This is rough—our
core colors aren’t even well-supported, and 10
is a low enough count for our off colors that
we’ll quite frequently be missing one or both
of them. However, if we dial the land count
up to 40 with equivalent per-card budget,
our count jumps back up to 20 for the
core colors and 13 for the off-colors,
the same as with the more tapland-oriented
30 land option. I should reiterate that
this still isn’t amazing, but it’s a good
demonstration of the tradeoffs involved
with building a mana base. I could go
into specific cycles of lands and when
they should or shouldn’t be used, but this
video is long enough already, so I won’t.
Instead, I want to talk more about the mana
symbols, and how to know how many of each
you’ll need. This is another area where lots of
people have posited various counts and formulas
and such-like, and to start with I’m gonna stick
with a familiar face. Frank Karsten also posted an
article offering an analysis of the number of each
symbol a deck should run in order to consistently
be able to play a card when they have enough total
mana, with “consistently” being 89+M% of the time,
where M is the mana value of a card. One
application of this formula and resulting
table would be to apply it to every single card in
your deck, and then build a mana base that gets as
close as possible to satisfying this for every
single card. This works in faster formats where
most or all cards want to be played on curve, but
it works a bit less well in EDH. I do think it’s
appropriate to apply this strict 89+M% standard
for pivotal cards you want to land on curve, such
as a commander or a ramp spell. However, for stuff
you need a little later such as high drops, combo
pieces, or removal, you can put them behind a
substantially lower symbol count as long as you’ve
got enough draw and ramp to help you get the
needed symbols by the time you need those cards.
This doesn’t necessarily mean you should totally
let your guard down on that sort of stuff,
though ; certainly, if you’re running a lot of
colors or you’re running symbol heavy cards,
it’s worth taking a careful look at your
mana base to make sure things will work
out. I recommend checking out the
chart in Frank Karsten’s article,
which I linked in the description, but
as a bit of shorthand, 30 symbols in your
mana base will give you great access to
all but the most symbol-intensive cards,
25 symbols will give you great access to single
symbol cards and decent access to double symbol
cards, 20 will give you decent access to single
symbol cards and mediocre access to more symbols,
and 15 symbols will give you okay access to single
symbol cards but will be unreliable beyond that.
For an example of one of my manabases, my Meria
deck runs 37 lands, with 23 red symbols and 22
green symbols. The deck is pretty low curved and
has a three mana commander that ramps, so the
lands and symbols are mostly to make sure that I
can drop the commander on curve consistently. When
I run this deck through Frank Karsten’s land count
formula, it’s right on the money, which makes
sense to me since the commander ramps, which would
make me okay with fewer lands, but also draws,
which would make me fine with more. For my Glissa
deck, I’m running 41 total lands, with 31 green
sources and 22 black sources. This count might
sound high, but it’s totally justifiable: it’s a
high-curved deck, it has card draw in the command
zone, and its ideal mana curve is elf on one,
commander on 2. Having mana issues my first three
turns will dramatically slow down the deck, as
it won’t be able to get its draw and ramp online,
so I’m comfortable with a pretty high land count.
In fact, Karsten’s formula generates an even
higher count of 43-and-some-change, which might
be partially because the deck’s average mana value
of 4.71 would likely be an outlier in Karsten’s
data set, but there are legitimate arguments for
adding lands to the deck. Regardless, a general
pattern across my decks is that even when they're
relatively low-curved, I still generally run a
high-30s quantity of lands in them as long as they
can draw a lot of cards. Mana screw is optional,
if you run a deck with big draw, running
more lands is your way of unticking that box.
I’ve covered a lot of stuff in this video and have
meandered a little bit, so let me clarify what I’m
actually trying to say here. For one, you should
be intentional with the number of lands you run,
and keep in mind that the optimal number might be
higher than the sorts of numbers that get thrown
around on the internet. Frank Karsten’s formula
for the ideal count is a good start, though since
it wasn’t designed with EDH in mind it may be
correct to deviate from it in some cases. You
can run fewer lands if your commander provides
a consistent way to draw into additional lands
in the early game, but you should always check
your symbol counts to make sure you have enough
to play your important cards when you need to,
and you should also keep in mind that if you’re
running a deck that runs a lot of big, expensive
draw, keeping your land count high will almost
certainly make the deck stronger. A land base will
naturally perform two functions—achieving total
mana values of cards and achieving colored symbols
for cards, and neither goal can be ignored. These
goals can be modulated to some extent by running
certain types of lands—running taplands that
offer more colors can be good in a deck that
is color hungry but doesn’t need as much speed,
and colorless-producing utility lands can be nice
for a deck that wants a higher land count but
already feels comfortable color-wise. You can also
replace nonland cards with utility lands or MDFCs
if you’re looking to up your land count without
adding cards that do nothing but add mana. I
didn’t talk much about taplands and utility lands
in general because this script was looking a
little thick already, but I’ll get back to those
at some point. Regardless, just pay attention to
your mana base. If you still can’t fully think
of it as a part of your deck, you should at least
think of it as your little helper—if you show
your mana base the love and appreciation you show
your nonland cards, it’ll pay you back by helping
you actually do the things your deck wants to do.
Fun update, I have a discord
now, link in the pinned comment,
so go join that if you feel like. Though
first you should click the buttons—subscribe,
like, dislike, and the other ones too.
Preferably you should click all of them,
in rapid succession. I hear if you click them just
right they give you some sort of prize. Good luck.